she's an American singer songwriter
actress reality TV star and fashion
designer she rose to fame with the
release of her debut single I want to
love you forever she's the founder of
the Jessica Simpson Collection a fashion
line clothing that's worth a billion
dollars
she's Jessica Simpson and here her top
10 rules for success we always take
trips we'll go to Paris and we'll do our
inspiration shopping but I love to go
into vintage stores I love to go into
vintage record stores I mean I'm
inspired by art and music I love and
appreciate every you know every person
out there whether it be a musician or
you know I have all these I collect
vintage records and so it's I think
album art is always a cool way to be
inspired as well I think we're gonna
always learn from other people's
mistakes I mean being in the public eye
for so long I've I've made a ton of
mistakes and everybody knows about him
but I I don't look at I look at my
mistakes and any sort of failure that I
have gone through as a lesson to be
learned and I I worked through it I and
what I truly remain inspired by each and
every woman that I meet my mother is a
huge part of my business she is my
mentor throughout all of this and she's
been styling me since I came out of the
womb and I trust her with my business
and just being a part of it with her and
all of all of our design teams it's not
just me it's not just my ideas and I
think that it's really important to
humble yourself and really understand
that you would never have the business
that you have if it weren't for all the
people that are helping you get there I
feel like the most empowering lesson
that I have learned is failure is okay
sometimes and in that we grow and we
learn from that and there's success
around the corner and you know we have
done so many different things within
growing this brand and it just continues
it continues to keep on keeping on and
we're just very very blessed and when I
say we're I'm it's not just me that is
my brand there are so many people that
deserve the credit for the Jessica
Simpson Collection I've had flight
attendants come up to me and say I have
to wear Jessica Simpson shoes because
they're the only ones that are
comfortable for me to stand on the whole
flight you know I mean I have and I
listened yeah I think that that's
important too is like really just
listening to your customer and to the
people that are giving you the feedback
whether it's criticism or or you know
like honoring and being people like
thank you so much I met the cutest guy
last night because of that dress that I
wore you know I look I listen to all of
it that it's okay to cry and it's okay
to feel upset because there's always
perseverance and there's always success
and there's always a way to get back up
and make it happen again
so I think that within any moment if you
see somebody you know and locked in
their fear I encourage you to go and
speak to them and help them through it I
feel like I was always taught to just
believe that success is right around the
corner and I truly feel successful but
there's still so much left to do and I
think that and not and not stopping or
or thinking that okay well wow that was
that was great now
you know this is always looking forward
and looking for a new adventure and
staying authentic to who I am and to
what my brand is well I think of it I
can relate to every woman out there I
have been every size there is so I know
how to dress every everybody type I
truly believe that you know it's not
just about high-fashion
we all need pieces in our wardrobe that
are fashionable but accessible wearable
you know and affordable I think that
that's really what has made the brand
such a success what were your
expectations of yourself I mean did you
ever think it could turn into something
like this I had no idea I mean we really
just started out with shoes and
accessories and now we're going into
active wear and we have maternity and
we're going into home and fragrance oh
hopefully opening stores soon so it's
just it's continuing to expand and girl
everyday the team around me respects
that I give them the credit and they
want to work for me they want they want
the line to succeed because they believe
in me and so to surround myself with
with family and the people that work on
the collection it's it's just it's the
heart of it's the heart of my business
and I appreciate each and every one of
them and I would never ever take the
credit thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Robyn Nicole
songwriter asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Jessica
Simpson's top ten rules meant the most
to you leave it in the comments and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon